une sirène dans les eaux yvelinoise la
plaisir oise julie peugeot 30 ans baigne
dans le maire meding depuis un an une
discipline insolite qui allie natation
et beauté avec un costume de femme
poisson en élasthanne ces disciplines
requiert une préparation physique la
sportive plonge deux fois par semaine en
piscine fermée dit est un sport on nous
demande des performances en apnée en
général je suis sur 40 secondes à une
minute 15 morts
vous avez
des figures à faire si vous souhaitez en
effet elles sont pas imposés mais en
effet il ya des vernis on doit aussi
également savoir poser sous l'eau on va
dire en mode très statique en complément
julie s'entraîne trois fois par semaine
sur terre dans une salle de sport
sécession lui ont permis de se présenter
au concours miss france de la discipline
une épreuve qu'elle a remporté en
juillet dernier en bretagne face à huit
candidates
je m'attendais pas du tout à gagner pas
du tout j'étais allée ont plutôt en mode
plutôt de défi personnel
je voulais vivre aussi une expérience
avec d'autres sirènes parce que c'est
pas tous les jours que l'on peut
rencontrer des sirènes en france donc
cet événement nous vous a permis de nous
regrouper de nous partager nos valeurs
nos connaissances nos savoir faire un
titre que la jeune sportive à bord
firman la piscine salvador allende des
clayes-sous-bois son lieu d'entraînement
depuis plusieurs mois ici tout le monde
est sous le charme de cette sirène d'un
mètre 65
je trouve que c'est une activité un peu
un peu spécial mais très sympa un peu
magique
un peu comme ça donc dans un premier
temps on va l'accueillir et puis après
on va essayer de faire une activité avec
les gens qui puisse nager avec elle avec
de la musique
julie espère désormais participer à un
concours international de sirène
programmé en egypte en 2020 avec un
objectif en tête ramener une nouvelle
fois les sharp à la maison